[موسيقى]
وسجن صيدنايا كان مفتتح حديثا
فكان في بعض الشروط تختلف كليا عن سجن
تدمر يعني بمعنى بمعنى تعذيب يومي ما في
ما كان في تعذيب يومي طبعا هلا اختلف
الموضوع صار اسوء شيء بس
حتى بعد 2011 يعني
اول ما رحنا اول ما فتح السجن يعني
87 نحن كنا موجودين في يعني لسه كان اثار
تشطيبات البناء موجود يعني
فكان في تحسن بشروط الانسانيه
التحسن بشروط الانسانيه بيعطي شويه
استرخاء عدا عن ذلك يعني فتحوا زيارات
فتحه الزيارات
صار بشكل منتظم
[موسيقى]
يعني حسب ما فهمت بالروايه انه كان في
معتقلات وسجون خمس نجوم
يعني على قياسا بتدمر بهالمواصفات هذا سجن
سيدنا كان خمس نجوم
لان هذا المقصود على كل الاصعده يعني مجرد
انه يعني فيك تزور اهلك يعني
ميزات يعني
[موسيقى]